sens public continue cette semaine c'est
une rétrospective des événements
marquants de l'année que je vous propose
les Bouver Semens économique majeur on
en parlera demain le bilan de
l'actualité internationale ce sera
mercredi ce soir c'est l'année politique
que l'on analyse avant de découvrir les
personnalités choisies par nos invités
on revient sur les dates clés de 2023
avec Jérôme Rabier c'était annoncé comme
la bataille du quinquena la réforme des
retraites présentée en janvier par
ellisabeth
en effet animé les premiers mois de
l'année 2023 d'abord dans la rue où un
front syndical uni rassemble pendant
plusieurs mois des millions de personnes
et au Parlement la bataille à fait rage
à l'Assemblée la stratégie d'obstruction
de la gauche empêche d'adopter le texte
au Sénat la bataille est rude mais un
texte est finalement adopté par la
droite sénatoriale et un compromis
trouvé mais pour faire adopter le texte
à l'Assemblée la première ministre
utilise le
493 rupture assez forte avec cette
réforme des retraites parce qu'elle aura
été vue rétrospectivement à la fois
comme une régression sociale le fait que
nous allions tous devoir travailler plus
longtemps et en même temps une
régression démocratique dans la façon où
elle a été adoptée ce qui me frappe
c'est que c'est la première fois que
l'usage d'un outil constitutionnel va à
ce point-là devenir l'outil d'une
contestation sociale elle-même la
séquence retraite à peine refermée
l'exécutif est confronté à une nouvelle
crise avec les émeutes qui suivent la
mort de Naël un jeune tué par un
policier pendant plusieurs jours des
villes s'embras pour Emmanuel Macron
après les gilets jaunes du premier
quinquena et les manifestations retraite
du début d'année c'est donc les banlieux
qui prennent le relais de la colère ces
trois colères là aussi intense et aussi
rapproché disent quelque chose me
semble-t-il et d'une intensification du
jeu social et d'une accélération du
temps social et d'une aggravation des
colères les crises ne sont heureusement
pour lui pas réservé à l'exécutif la
gauche connaît aussi son lot cette année
la nup qui avait permis de sauver les
meubles au législativ l'an dernier a
fini par exploser ça n'est une surprise
pour personne dans les idéologies mais
c'est vrai que ça va sûrement poser des
questions sur la survie en fait de de
cette discipline de groupe qui avait été
un petit peu trouvée au moins autour de
la réforme des retraites on voit que
depuis le départ c'est non pas sur le
fond mais dans la posture d'opposition
dans la radicalité parfois assumée et
même surjouée qu'il peut y avoir de
vrais désaccords à gauche en face la
droite conserve fin septembre le pouvoir
au Palais du Luxembourg en remportant
les sénatoriales avec ses alliés
centristes pas une surprise mais un
élément déterminant pour la suite du
quinquena le gouvernement va devoir
penser avec les républicains et avec le
Sénat et la loi immigration c'est le
symbole même d'une loi qui peut porter
l'identité républicaine l'identité LR le
texte immigration est donc d'abord
étudié au Sénat qui le durcit fortement
mais coup de théâtre à l'Assemblée une
motion de rejet est adoptée empêchant
son examen une sérieuse alerte pour
l'exécutif on voit que Emmanuel Macron
et sa majorité parlementaire qui n'en
est pas une vont avoir beaucoup de mal à
gouverner pendant les plus de 3 années
qu'il nous reste si 2023 aura été une
année agitée 2024 promet aussi de lêre
au programme une nouvelle loi travail
qui pourrait remettre les syndicats au
premier plan ou encore le début de
l'examen d'un projet de loi sur la fin
de
un thème de société qui peut aussi
fracturer les Français sur la délicate
question de
l'euthanasie on tire les leçons de cette
année politique 2023 avec mes invités
laurenceerveau bonsoir vous êtes
directrice du cercle de réflexion destin
commun Pascal Perino bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi politologue professeur à
Science Po Paris Richard verli bonsoir
et bienvenue le correspondant France
Europe pour le médiia Suisse BL on est
également en duplexe avec jeandiel Levi
directeur délégué de Harry saint
interactive
bonsoir jeandiel et Mathieu croissand
évidemment est rester à mes côté donc je
vous ai demandé aux uns et aux autres de
choisir plusieurs événements ou
personnalités marquant de de de de cette
année
2023 Laurence deerveau je vous vouliez
revenir sur les les émeutes qui suivent
la mort de de Naël on est le 27 juin
quand il est tué à boutportant par un
policier lors d'un refus de d'obtempéré
avec 6 mois de recul quelle leçons vous
tirez finalement de ces de ces journées
de violence peut-être aussi comment
elles ont été perçu par les Français oui
alors remettons-nous un petit peu dans
le contexte dans l'ambiance juste après
la mort de ce jeune et les émeutes
urbaines qui ont suivi le pays dans son
ensemble est dans un état de sidération
évidemment face à à ce décès mais aussi
face à à ces émeutes qui ont été assez
largement incomprises sur le moment mais
surtout ce qui a dominé à ce moment-là
c'est une forme de polarisation dans
dans le la façon dont l'opinion a été
décrite il y aurait il y aurait eu deux
pays en fait de France face à face comme
on aime tellement la raconé la France de
la cagnotte a et de la cagnotte B il
fallait que chacun choisisse son camp
entre le camp des policiers le camp des
jeunes de quartier en réalité deux
cagnottes qui avaient été monté voilà
c'est ça en réalité cette vision là
était très caricaturale ne correspondait
pas du tout à l'opinion des Français qui
étaient beaucoup plus nuancé ça vous
l'avez vraiment étudié précisément voà
on l'a mesuré 10 jours après la mort de
du jeune Naël un sondage qui a été
réalisé du 7 au 9 juillet et qui
montrait que trois Français sur quatre
disaient qu'ils étaient à la fois en
colère de la mort du jeune mais aussi
qu'il considérait que la police avait
une mission extrêmement difficile dans
leur ensemble les Français étaient
plutôt très largement en soutien des
policiers donc la vision d'une France
antiflic qui a beaucoup été poussé aussi
à ce moment-là ne correspondait pas non
plus à la réalité les Français
considéraient que les policiers méritent
notre respect pour autant ils étaient
aussi conscients de de problèm de de
racisme au sein de la police sans
nécessairement les considérer comme
systémiques donc vous voyez à tous les
niveaux on trouve en réalité une forme
de nuance et de prise en compte de la
complexité dans l'opinion des Français
sur sur cet épisode Pascal Perino parmi
les événements que vous aviez choisis il
y avait aussi ces C ces émeutes de du
début d'été est-ce que l'analyse que que
nous livre laurenceerveau vous vous
surprend d'une certaine façon est-ce que
vous faites la même non non je crois
qu'en effet il y a une comment dire une
subtilité dans l'opinion publique une
capacité à à ne pas être dans le blanc
ou dans le noir qui est évidente et
qu'on voit dans toutes dans toutes les
enquêtes euh avec cependant une
tonalité qui est en effet du côté de la
police
hein on a trop souvent
tendance à présenter la population
française comme étant une population qui
n'aimerait pas sa police quand vous
regardez les enquêtes c'est très
différent vous savez que la police c'est
l'institution préférée des Français
après l'armée l'armée c'est du 90 % mais
la police c'est très souvent même à la
suite de ces événements extrêmement
douloureux qui mon monde qu'il y a un
versant il peut y avoir un versant de
violence policière c'est plus de 60 % de
Français qui considèrent qui ont une
image favorable de la police et c'est le
cas chez les jeunes aussi hein une
majorité absolue de jeunes de 18 à 24
ans une image positive de la police mais
c'est bien sûr c'est pas les jeunes que
l'on voit dans la rue c'est pas les
jeunes dont on parle bien s s mais il y
a une majorité absolue hein vous voyez
on va contre des des des idées toutes
faites mais je si vous voulez on
s'interroge beaucoup aujourd'hui sur la
continuation d'une dynamique du
rassemblement national tout à fait
impressionnante et on se dit mais au
fond pourquoi qu'est-ce qui explique
cela et et je crois qu'il y a un effet
relapse un effet qui a
attendu de ces émeutes dans l'opinion
publque française en faveur du
rassemblement on y reviendra un peu plus
tard parce que vous avez les uns et les
autres pas tous mais choisi notamment
Jordan Berdella parmi les personnalités
politiques à faire ressortir de cette
année 2023 je reste sur ce sur ces éme
de 553 villes françaises touchées c'est
ça fait partie
des
Villy bien sûr ça fait partie des des
leçons et des surprises de de de lié à
cet événement et un président de la
République qui promet des réponses
profonde
écoutez nous aurons à apporter les
réponses profonde aux émeutes que le
pays a vécu début du mois de juillet car
au-delà des réponses d'urgence nous
voyons bien à travers les les crises que
le risque de de fragmentation de
division profonde de la nation est là et
il y a un
besoin tout à la fois
d'autorité de respect d'espérance
légitime et c'est une réponse complète
et profonde qui se joue à l'échelle de
la nation cétait en en ouverture du
premier Conseil des ministres avec la
nouvelle équipe gouvernementale qui
n'avait pas finalement beaucoup changé
par rapport à la à la précédente Richard
Verly 6 mois plus
tard parmi les informations de de cette
semaine il y a la ministre des
Solidarités des familles qui annonçaient
des des mesures pour à l'encontre des
parents défaillants est-ce que pour vous
le gouvernement français comme le
souhaitait Emmanuel Macron a pris la la
mesure de ce qui s'est passé en juillet
je pense que le gouvernement a pris la
mesure il sait ce qui s'est passé il a
sans doute commandité des études il a
pris connaissance de toutes les études
qui ont été faites mais les réponses
structurelles puisque c'est le thème
employé par Emmanuel Macron moi
personnellement je ne les vois pas
quelle a été une réponse structurelle je
ne serais personnellement pas capable
d'en citer une seule et ce que vous
dites sur les sanctions à appliquer au
parents supposément défaillant ça n'a
rien de nouveau moi je l'ai entendu
plein de fois ce refrain donc peut-être
est-ce une solution et encore faudrait
qu'il en débatte parce que là-dessus les
avis sont très partagés et les effets
induits de ce type de politique peuvent
être discutables mais en tout cas ça ça
n'a rien de nouveau et jusqu'à
maintenant on n jamais été capable de le
faire donc il faut bien dire que si on
prend le président Macron à la lettre et
bien pour l'instant rien ne s'est fait
ou rien n'a été fait de convaincant qui
permettent aujourd'hui de dire ça y est
on a commencé à prendre le problème à
bras LEC ouais vous avez choisi Gabriel
Attal comme parmi les personnalités de
l'année en fait je je vous donne les les
coulisses j'ai demandé à tous nos
invités plusieurs dates et plusieurs
personnalités puis ensuite nous on a un
peu équilibré tout ça est-ce que vous
vous reliez finalement
le choix de Gabri à ce qui s'est passé
justement en juillet en France est-ce
que il a à sa façon tiré les leçons des
émeutes je crois oui c'est un des rares
c'est un des rares dans le dispositif
gouvernemental qui commence à apporter
des réponses parce que ces émeutes elle
pose deux types de questions elle pose
la question du recours croissant en
particulier chez les jeunes à des
comportements violents et puis elle pose
la question de l'intégration al
l'intégration il y a pas 36 réponses
l'intégration ça se fait avant tout par
l'école républicaine et là on a et par
la famille bien sûr euh on a tout de
même un un ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui dans une France qui est
très inquiète sur le terrain de
l'éducation l'éducation est haute euh
est en haut des des préoccupations des
Français euh les Français sentent bien
qu'il y a quelque chose qui se défait en
matière d'éducation ils ne sont plus
aussi fiers qu'ils étaient de leur
éducation nationale et là on a un
ministre qui semble avoir pris la mesure
du défi la mesure de l'inquiétude la
mesure du défi et qui apporte euh toute
une série euh euh de mesures là aussi on
l'a vu euh quand il a affirmé réaffirmé
l'interdiction de la baaya euh on a vu
quant à la suite de l'attentat horrible
d'aras il a pris des mesures et il a
ordonné l'exclusion je crois de 68
élèves qui ne s'étit euh le moins qu'on
puisse dire pas tenu correctement lors
de la cérémonie d'hommage et puis
maintenant il rentre dans le dur il dit
en particulier à la suite de cette
enquête catastrophique PISA qui comp sa
les élèves de 15 ans dans les pays de
l'OCDE voilà de de l'OCDE qui sont très
inquiétante en ce qui concerne la
maîtrise par les jeunes français de la
technique de la lecture et des
mathématique il a dit voilà il faut
baisse un peu partout mais
particulièrement en France mais
particulièrement en France il faut choc
des savoirs alors tiens justement
l'électrochoc souhaité par Gabriel hatal
je vous propose d'écouter un extrait de
sa sa prise de parole c'est le jour
effectivement où l'enquête PISA est
publiée aujourd'hui j'assume de porter
une ambition très forte pour l'école
sans aucun tabou ce que nous allons
mettre en place ce doit être un
véritable électrochoc un électrochoc
pour remettre l'exigence à tous les
étages un électrochoc pour remettre les
savoirs fondamentaux au cœur de la
promesse de l'école un électrochoc qui
qui s'adresse aux élèves qui relancera
l'ascenseur scolaire confortera la place
du professeur et redonnera confiance aux
familles Mathieu voulit intervenir il a
une originalité je trouve c'est que
d'abord il donne de la voix une voix qui
est entendue dans un gouvernement qui a
parfois du mal à exister vocalement il y
a des ministres qui sont confrontés à
des sujets autrement important je pense
à Christophe Béchu qui a eu du mal à se
faire entendre Gabriel Atal lui a fait
qu'on entend sa voix deuxièmement il
rétablit quelque chose s'appelle la
parole performative c'est quand vous
dites et que les choses se font qu'
raccourc consid ement le temps de
l'action politique à un moment où un
nombre de projets sont décalés parce que
tout est long je prends la fin de vie
l'immigration ça a pris 18 mois voilà
lui il dit j'interdis la baaya la baaya
est interdite il dit on décale le bac en
juin le bac est décalé en juin donc et
c'est assez rare d'avoir un ministre qui
comme ça peut peut prendre des décisions
qui qui
s'engagent politique je vais vous Ronner
la parole juste après mais pour une
première fois parce qu'on l'a pas encore
entendu jeanel l je voudrais savoir
comment vous analysez vous le phénomène
Atal est-ce qui vous semble comment
comment dire durable c'estàdire
s'appuyer sur des ressorts assez
profonds oui absolument je rejoins ce
que disait Pascal Perino c'est que la la
thématique de l'éducation constitue un
des aspects auquels les Français sont
aujourd'hui le plus attentif pas
uniquement d'ailleurs les parents ou les
grands-parents mais l'ensemble de la
population française qui est inquiète
pas uniquement pour leurs enfants
aujourd'hui pas uniquement pour
l'éducation aujourd'hui mais également
sur les perspectives d'avenir et dans le
casadre des enquêtes qu'on peut être
amené à réaliser on voit qu'il y a un
lien intime entre la perception d'une
société française et d'une France qui
serait sur le déclin et la contribution
de notre système éducatif et dans ce
contexte-là ce que dit Gabriel Atal
c'est le politique peut faire quelque
chose le politique peut prendre des
positions qui plus a ne sont pas
toujours perçu comme étant forcément
uniformes ou perçu de la même manière
par l'ensemble de la population
française mais elles apparaissent comme
étant claires précises réactives par
rapport à des enjeux qui renvoi à
l'immédiat et également aux perspectives
d'avenir donc dans ce contexte là
effectivement il y a une capacité pour
Gabriel Atal à pouvoir progresser très
nettement dans toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion qu'on réalise depuis qu'il est
ministre de l'éducation nationale un mot
chacun sur Gabriel Atal il y a beaucoup
d'autres thème donc je vous demande
d'aller assez vite l' de ner oui Gabriel
Atal est aussi à l'évidence un fin
politique le choix de faire de laaba le
sujet de la rentrée scolaire alors qu'il
venait d'être nommé ministre de
l'éducation nationale était évidemment
extrêmement tactique puisque c'est le
sujet qui a c'est un des sujets qui à
l'automne a fait exploser la gauche
autour de leur conception de la laïcité
on a vu que ça a créé beaucoup de
tension au sein de laanupes donc il
avait aussi ça dans dans dans ce choix
et dans le fait de porter sujet à ce
moment-là c'était aussi une demande des
chefs d'établissement qui voulait de la
clarté sur question moi je vais citer un
souvenir de ce plateau à Sens publique
je me souviens que Gael Sliman était
intervenu sur la personnalité préférée
des Français et il avait dit une chose
qui à ce moment-là m'avait surpris et
maintenant je le comprends c'est que
Gérald n'imprimait pas du tout dans la
population rappelez-vous Thomas il le
disait c'était bien avant le rejet
préalable du texte alors que Gabriel
Atal imprimé clairement c'estàd qu'au
fond et bien les Français ils ont
compris les Français ils sont beaucoup
plus clairvoyants qu'on le pense ils
savent déceler les responsables
politiques qui agissent et qui sont
capables d'obtenir des résultats alors
il y a l'une des questions importantes
de de de cette de ce bilan de l'année
politique qui concerne vous avez
commencé à l'évoquer Pascal Perino le
rassemblement national est-il le grand
gagnant de l'année 2023 vous êtes deux à
avoir choisi parmi vos personnalités de
de l'année Lauro et Pascal Perino Jordan
Bardella le président du Rassemblement
national on va l'écouter c'était à la à
la sortie des rencontres de Saint-Denis
à la première des premières rencontrre
de Saint-Denis où il avait été convié
par le président de République comme
tous les chefs de parti représentés au
Parlement Jordane
Bardella le débat était franc
euh quand vous êtes quand vous êtes à
viclot que les camérats sont pas là vous
avez un langage qui est peut-être un peu
plus un peu plus familier un peu plus
franc je lui ai dit ce que j'avais sur
le cœur et ce que pensaient des millions
de Français de la politique qu'il
conduisait que j'ai trouvé assez dur
peut-être encore plus dur depuis sa
réélection en
2022 pourquoi Jordan Bardella Pascal
Perino pour différ pas Marine Le Pen non
non pour pour différentes raisons
d'ailleurs Marine Le Pen est concernée
c'est que Marine Le Pen a su transmettre
le pouvoir dans le parti à la jeune
génération c'est tellement rare dans les
partis des transmissions de génération
qui se font comme cela pour l'instant
oui c'est réel c'est pas cosmétique non
non non non c'est pas cosmétique c'est
pas cosmétique et lui donne tout de même
un certain champ il a la tête de liste
une fois de plus aux
européennes les sondages l'annoncent à
points devant la liste qui serait la
liste de la majorité d'ailleurs demain
on vous proposera un sondage sur ce
thème je peux pas encore vous le révéler
mais il est assez édifiant voilà euh et
d'autre part se met en place quelque
chose de très efficace dans la dynamique
du rassemblement national c'est une
division du travail entre deux rôles
Marine Le Pen qui parle j'allais dire à
la clientèle traditionnelle du
rassemblement national qui a une
légitimité que n'a pas encore Jordan
Bardella dans cette population et un
Jordan Bardella qui est un chevau léger
qui va chercher vers d'autres horizons
une capacit du rassemblement national à
s'étendre vers de nouvelles couches
sociales vers de nouvelles générations
je suis frappé par exemple que dans les
dernières élections dans les derniers
sondages sur les élections européennes
il y a une reprise sensible du
rassemblement national chez les jeunes
Jordan Bardella est un des leaders les
plus jeunes dans l'offre politique et il
y a certainement quelque chose à voir
jean-dianiel levier est-ce que
effectivement les deux là on est en
train de parler de Jordan Bella et de
Marine Le Pen ne touch pas
exactement le même électorat est-ce que
vous nous diriez ça non il touche
effectivement il touche effectivement
pas tout à fait exactement le même le
même électorat avec une capacité de
Jordan bardela effectivement à pouvoir
accroître un peu l'espace de ce que peut
être le rassemblement national à faire
en sorte qu'on pensait qu'il y avait
déjà une assise assez importante auprès
de la jeunesse mais que celle-ci
continue de progresser ce qui d'ailleurs
est assez impressionnant c'est que à
aucun moment ni Marine Le Pen ni
Bardella ne font état du fait que des
responsabilités ont été confiées à des
jeunes au sein du rassemblement national
il le prouveent directement et sans en
faire une forme d'argument marketing tel
que cela peut être fait notamment de la
part d'autres responsables politiques
qui sont amenés à dire nous faisons une
place aux jeunes et donc ça cette forme
d'efficacité avec un langage qui plusit
qui apparaît comme étant clair aussi
bien la part de Marine Le Pen que de la
part de Monsieur Bardella laurenceer
est-ce qu'il peut finir par faire de
l'ombre à Marine Le Pen ou est-ce que
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop
tôt pour dire ça alors c'est bien sûr la
question aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que si
on on se remet quelques années en
arrière le rassemblement national
n'avait qu'une tête aujourd'hui
clairement il en a deux il a pris le
parti en main par ailleurs si on regarde
en terme de registre et de perception
effectivement il y a des différence
nette mais on voit que Jordan Bardella
pourrait prendre l'avantage nous avions
mené en juin dernier une étude sur
l'évolution de l'image du rassemblement
national auprès de l'électorat modéré
celui qui traditionnellement ne vote pas
ou pas encore pour l'extrême droite et
on avait demandé en fait aux Français de
qualifier Marine Le Pen en la rattachant
à une marque ou un produit de
consommation et il y a eu tout un
registre autour de ce qu'on a appelé la
ringardisation certaines personnes
disaient en fait c'est comme le wman ou
Nintendo voyez des marques qui
n'existent même plus qui sont dépassées
et
bienement soyez pas désagréableors si
Marine Le Pen c'est le Walkman en fait
Jenal Barl là c'est Spotify voyez et ça
rejoint une sorte de pipolisation de
Jordane Bardella un petit peu presque à
la Obama chemise blanche un peu ouverte
manche retroussé qui monte sur les étrat
donc les estrad en courant et qui est
aujourd'hui très pipelisé notamment
auprès des jeunes alors la question
c'est est-ce qu'effectivement Marine Le
Pen a pris un réel risque dans la
perspective de 2027 en lui donnant
autant de place et au-delà de l'image et
c'est ça ce sur quoi il faut insister
par ailleurs Jordan Bardella pourrait
être celui qui fait sauter la digue de
l'amateurisme qui est encore ce qui est
très souvent reproché à Marine Le Pen et
deux autres points toujours sur cette
différenciation entre les deux il n'a
pas le nom Le Pen qui pour certains peut
encore être une derrière et il a à
l'inverse alors et puis peut-être que
certains électeurs très conservateurs ne
voteraient pas pour une femme au moment
de mettre le bulant dans juste un
complément le plus classique d'extrême
droite n'est pas celui qu'on pense c'est
qu'il a vieille génération nouvelle
génération mais le plus identitaire des
deux plus le plus extrême droite des
deux en formaté c'est Jordan Bardella
par d'idéie d'idéologie bien s un mot
Richard ver parce que alors dans les
sous quelques plumes perfid ou pas je ne
sais pas mais se murmure que celui qui
travaille le plus c'est lui que c'est un
vrai bosseur alors que Marine Le Pen ne
l'est pas vraiment écoutez on en a eu je
ne sais pas si c'est la preuve qu'il
travaille mais en tout cas la preuve de
sa la perception de Jordan Bardella on
l'a eu il y a quelques jours lorsqu'il a
déclaré qu'il était prêt à assumer le
poste de Premier ministre vous avez
remarqué que personne n'a réagi personne
n'a dit que c'était impossible personne
ne s'est levé en disant qu'un jeune
homme sans grand diplôme parce qu'il n'a
pas fait une il n'a pas des diplômes
prestigieux universitaires genre sur
ou autr personne n'a rien dit à partir
du moment où vous pouvez dire je suis
prêt Premier ministre que personne ne
réagit c'està qu'au fond ça apparaît
presque normal ça veut quand même dire
que vous avez relativement gagné allez
Mathie croiss a raison de rappeler que
sur le fond les idées sont
particulièrement radicales il y a
beaucoup d'événements forcément c'est le
principe d'un d'un bilan politique d'une
année il a fallu faire des choix qui
étaient pas simple on ne pouvait pas
passer à côté de cet autre événement
politique majeur la réforme des
retraites 3 3 mois d'unité syndicale de
manifestation monstre du 10 janvier c la
date de la présentation du texte
jusqu'au 15 avril lorsque la loi est
promulguée avec une date que vous avez
choisi Richard verli qui est devenu le
le symbole du passage en force 16 mars
Élisabeth born choisit la sécurité c'est
pour ça en dégainant le
493 on ne peut pas faire de Paris sur
l'avenir de nos retraite cette réforme
est
nécessaire
aussi parce que je suis attaché à notre
modèle social et parce que je crois dans
la démocratie
parlementaire c'est sur votre réforme
sur le texte du Parlement fruit d'un
compromis entre les deux assemblées que
je suis prête à engager ma
responsabilité aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 modifié par
l'amendement de coordination communiqué
à l'Assemblée
nationale 16 mars 2023 Richard verli
pour vous c'est une fracture oui c'est
la preuve que il y a un sentiment de
brutalisation institutionnelle alors
j'ai bien entendu les argument de tous
les politologues tous les experts qui
expliquent à juste titre que l'article
493 est constitutionnel qu'il a été
prévu pour faire fonctionner la
République que la constitution de la 5e
République est particulièrement
plastique qu'elle s'adapte et bien à mon
avis non elle ne s'adapte plus le 493
reste comme un stigmate maintenant sur
le front d'Emmanuel Macron il est
l'homme qui brutalise le Parlement il
est l'homme qui brutalise la démocratie
bien entendu pour ses détracteurs pas
pour ses partisans et ça je crois que ça
va rester et regardez Michel Rocard
Michel Rocard à l'épque de cohabitation
a beaucoup utilisé le 493 mais personne
n'associe Michel rard à l'utilisation du
493 ça a été oublié et bien je pense que
pour Emmanuel Macron ça ne sera pas
oublié je voudrais bien avoir l'avis de
jeandiel les là-dessus sur le peut-être
l'effet à long terme dans l'opinion de
de l'utilisation du 493 pour passer la
réforme de TR et peut-être de cette
réforme en général qui à mesure que les
générations la touche du Doig cette
réforme quel effet ça peut avoir à long
terme bah ce qui assez frappant c'est
que on retient comme nombre beaucoup
plus le nombre 493 que le nombre 64 64
c'est l'âge légal maintenant de départ à
la retraite et celui-ci apparaît
quasiment passé au second plan comme si
la forme avait pris le pas sur le fond
et donc on est face à des Français qui
ont eu effectivement le sentiment que le
gouvernement n'était pas entièrement
entre guillemets légitime que le
Président de la République n'était pas
entièrement légitime on peut rappeler
qu'on a moins d'un Français sur deux qui
s dépl placé au premier tour des
dernières élections législatives on peut
rappeler que pour la première fois
hormis peut-être en 1988 un président de
la République n'a pas eu une majorité
parlementaire à l'issue de l'élection
présidentielle et que tout ceci entraîne
une forme de distance assez marquée de
la part de nos compatriotes à l'égard du
493 alors il y a depuis eu recours au
493 à quelques reprises on l'a vu sur
les textes budgétaires mais dans un
contexte qui apparaissait comme étant
extrêmement différent notamment parce
que la mobilisation d'opinion et la
mobilisation dans la R était
effectivement beaucoup moins forte qu'à
l'époque de la réforme des retraites
avec la perception à l'époque de la du
du mouvement contre la réforme des
retraite que cette réforme était passée
au forceps contre l'opinion contre les
organisations syndicales et contre une
partie de la légitimité démocratique du
pays euh la gauche Mathieu aurait pu
tirer profit de ces 3 mois de
mobilisation et pourtant et pourtant il
n'en a rien été hein tout avait pourtant
pas si mal commencé on on en parlait la
réforme des retraites plus gros
mouvement social quand même depuis 1995
hmm sy gouvernement isolé une réforme
très impopulaire et que croyez-vous
qu'il en ai fait ben rien nada wou on se
souviendra de quoi de quelques insultes
à l'assemblée de casserolade pour cette
gauche carnavalesque elle est passée à
côté d'une occasion en ord de se
remettre en ortre de marche et de
reprendre des couleurs elle était
obsédée comme à son habitude par des
questions de tactiques divisé sur les
objectifs incapable de proposer un
contreprojet qui tienne la route et elle
n offert donc au français que le
spectacle d'une opposition braillarde
est désolante pour un résultat nul
puisque la réforme a été votée pendant
ce tempslà on en parlait sans bouger le
petit doigt bah le RN lui a volé la
place d'alternance crédible dans les
sondages pire la première force
d'opposition que la gauche prétendait
incarner avec la nupes 150 députés tout
de même à l'époque a finit par exploser
en fin d'année parce que le le leur
différence elles étaient insurmontable
mais parce qu'aucun n'a joué le jeu
insoumis PS communiste écolo chacun a
prétendu faire l'alliance tout en
continuant à avancer ses propres pions
les les insoumis ont considéré que leurs
partenaires comme des supplétifs qui
n'avaient pas leur mot à dire quant aux
autres ils ont fait semblant de dire oui
patron à Jean-Luc Mélenchon tout en se
préparant à partir en solo aux
prochaines élections européennes ce
grand jeu de dupe a fini par se voir et
euh par exploser les excès de Mélenchon
ont fait le reste hein on en parlera à
contrecourant de la demande d'ordre
exprimé par l'opinion lors des émeutes
qui ont suivi la mort de de du jeune Nil
on en parlait à contrecourant de
l'histoire en refusant de qualifier les
abominations du Hamas de terrorisme et
en refusant de défiler contre
l'antisémitisme la gauche radicale en
fait s'est recollé pour longtemps sur le
front l'étiquette d'irresponsable de
laaxiste et de complaisante avec les
islamistes quant à la gauche dit
réformiste elle est à faune faute de
projet alternatif comme de personnalités
pour le porter et puis elle fait des
trucs débiles tenez la semaine dernière
elle s'est tiré une balle d'empiier à
l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée en voulant
jouer au plus malin et en portant une
motion de rejet du texte sur
l'immigration elle n'a eu à la fois
qu'un boulevard pour les LR et un texte
encore plus dur que celui qu'elle
contestait donc est-ce qu'elle a quand
même quelques raison d'espérer en 2024 B
on verra les score des différentes
listes aux européennes mais avoir les
débuts de campagne poussif des uns et
des autres vous avez entendu parler de
la campagne des communistes non on la
voit pas celle des écologistes pour le
booty shake sur la scène de leur premier
meeting oui mais pour le reste pas
grand-chose donc il est quand même
permis d'en douter Richard verli sur sur
Jean-Luc Mélenchon puisquon on vous a
demandé des personnalités marquantes
est-ce qu'on pourrait le désigner comme
le grand perdant de cette année 2023 ou
pas je suis pas sûr parce que il il est
perdant évidemment parce qu'il a paraît
encore plus clivant pour tous ceux qui
doutaient de sa capacité à rassembler
mais il me semble quand même que dans la
franche d'opinion qui lui est favorable
il est perçu comme l'ultime résistant
euh et ça c'est même très préoccupant
parce qu'il y a un côté je trouve assez
sectaire autour du chef Mélenchon et le
chef Mélenchon me semble-t-il dans son
électorat n'est pas si ébranlé que ça je
me trompe peut-être mais je suis frappé
quand je parle de lui non pas à des
personnalités politiques ou à des
journalistes mais à des électeurs de
gauche notamment ceux qui lui
reconnaissent c'est qu'il a toujours
plaidé pour l'union de la gauche qui
n'aura pas lieu aux européennes alors
bien sûr on sait une union qu'il voulait
diriger lui-même mais l'union ça marche
à gauche et le regret que cette union
n'est pas lieu quelque part on lui
attribue le fait qu'au moins lui il a
essayé h alors vous avez choisi Laurence
deerveau parmi les personnalités
politique François Ruffin et ça
l'extrait qu'on va montrer qu'on va
regarder ensemble nous ramène à la à la
réforme des retraites c'était en avril
dernier il se présente le député LFI de
la la somme pour soutenir desg d'un site
de stockage de gaz on
l'écoute on a aujourd'hui un homme tout
seul là-haut qui a décidé de passer
cette réforme en force sur le reste du
pays avec 2 tiers des Français qui
disent non dans la durée quatre salariés
sur 5 qui sont quand même les premiers
concernés des millions de personnes dans
la rue une 2 3 4 5 6 fois tous les
syndicats unis et même une majorité de
députés à l'Assemblée si jamais on l'
laissé voter et cet homme seul là-haut
prétend imposer sa réforme à tout le
pays même pas pour des raisons
budgétaire mais aujourd'hui pour des
raisons autoritaires par éego par
orgueil par arrogance et ben toutes ces
actions viennent dire STOP ça suffit
Laurence Z pourquoi ce choix de François
est-ce que c'est l'une des seules ou la
seule personnalité de gauche à émerger
là de de de de cette gauche en Lisée qui
semble en Lisée je pense que 2023 a été
l'année de alors est-ce que c'est
l'envolé ou l'utopie François Ruffin en
tout cas de la mu de François Ruffin qui
étape par étape est en train de marquer
sa différence de prendre ses distan de
plus en plus avec familletique il faut
repartir de la toute fin de l'année 2022
grande interview dans l'OPS où François
Ruffin lui-même se qualifie comme social
et démocrate par le jeu d'un petit tiret
rajouté je pense par l'OPS on l'a
qualifié de socialdémocrate ce qui n'est
pas exactement la même chose et ce qu'il
a démenti mais toujours est-il que
François Ruffin n'est clairement plus
aujourd'hui sur la même ligne que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce qui n'est pas
toujours confortable pour lui parce
qu'il est toujours dans ce sur cette
ligne de crête en fait mais clairement
le le le la vision de Ruffin est quelque
chose plus de l'ordre du rassemblement
que celle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est
dans la conflictualisation permanente
conflictualisation qu'il a lui-même
théorisé dans un entretien dans la Revue
des Deux Mondes et c'est intéressant
aussi de revenir sur un épisode qui est
passé un petit peu en dessous des radars
médiatiques qui était le le les
universités d'été de LFI à Valence à la
toute fin du mois
d'août immense immense salle comble
devant laquelle François Ruffin a
dénoncé la radicalité de de Lafi qui
serait selon lui cite ces termes le
marqueur d'une culture minoritaire et il
a même appelé le mouvement de gauche à
gagner en centralité ce terme de
centralité va tout de même très loin
donc il a aussi il est très préoccupé
aussi par la forme il connaît le
l'efficacité de la stratégie de la
cravate du RN à l'Assemblée nationale
voilà donc tout ça et puis on voit que
étape par étape ces derniers mois euh je
je de mon point de vue il il a fait une
sorte de sans faute hein dans sur la
masse notamment sur le Hamas exactement
il a réussi à trouver cet équilibre hein
sur l'épisode de Crépol aussi il a parlé
démiplégiste c'estàd pourquoi
serait-on obligé soit de choisir le camp
du jeune Thomas soit de celui du jeune
Mourad enfin pas si jeune ça d'ailleurs
je ne sais plus peorte voilà François
rffin est en train de trouver cette
ligne de crête petit à petit alors la
grande question c'est est-ce qu'il aura
est-ce qu'il arrivera à transformer
l'ESS sur qui pourra-t-il compter et
puis est-ce que les électeurs le
suivront dans cette cette ligne vers la
modération ça m'intéresse d'entendre
Jean a su est-ce qu'il perce vraiment
François
Ruffin Jean-Daniel li il commence à
avoir une forme de notoriété après ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui pleinement
identifié de la part des Français pas
vraiment on sait que ça prend beaucoup
de temps euh on sait que quand on est
dans une forme de champ politique en
général euh le fait de pouvoir indiquer
qu'on a des différences des diversgences
d'opinion ou des différences
stratégiques prennent parfois plusieurs
mois ou plusieurs années c'est le cas à
l'heure actuelle encore pour euh
monsieur Ruffin eu il commence à être
connu c'est sa manière de parler son
phrasé une partie de son histoire sont
identifié de la part de nos compatriotes
on sait que il y a un certain nombre
d'acteurs politiques qui se disent
peut-être qu'il pourrait être à la tête
d'une forme de candidature commune des
socialistes des écologistes voir de
France insoumise dans le cadre de la
prochaine élection présidentielle mais
ça n'est pas exactement le niveau auquel
il peut être d'un point de vue d'opinion
c'est probablement à travers la force de
la répétition et peut-être à travers
l'attention des médias qu'il arrivera à
progresser encore et là aujourd'hui ce
qu'on pourrait qualifier une forme de
notoriété qui progresse sans que le
contenu politique ne soit 100 % associé
à ce qu'il peut être amené à raconter
alors il nous reste allez autour de 8
minutes pour conclure cette ce bilan de
l'année politique on va se concentrer
sur un dernier événement évidemment
majeur et vous êtes de à l'avoir choisi
Pascal Perino et et Richard verli la
marche contre l'antisémitisme organisé
le 12 novembre à Paris et dans plusieurs
villes de France Pascal périno je
commence avec vous quelle quelle leçon
vous en tirez de il y a eu à peu près
200000 personne en tout qui prêt à se
mobiliser ce ce jour-là en France si
vous voulez euh on pouvait douter de la
capacité de l'opinion publique française
euh à réagir surtout quand on regardait
l'absence de mobilisation de masse après
des meurtres antisémites hein que ce
soit ma
Toulouse que ce soit la
disparition d'
il y a eu de
multiples phénomènes o on se disait
tiens la France est en train de perdre
sa capacité de réaction à
l'antisémitisme l'antisémitisme qui
tuein et là on a eu une une heureuse
surprise une heureuse surprise avec en
effet sauf et les fill un arc
extrêmement large qui allait au-delà de
ce qu'on appelle l'arc républicain
traditionnel puisque pour la première
Ire fois le rassemblement national a été
avec des modalités diverses accepté au
fond dans ce dans ce défilé c'était pas
les partis qui défilaient c'était les
Français quel que soit leur sensibilité
qui disaient leur allergie à ce retour
d'un antisémitisme qui est un
antisémitisme nouveau parce que
l'insertion du rassemblement national de
militant du rassemblement national dans
cette marche ça voulait dire que
l'antisémite
n'était plus principalement là où on
l'attendait l'antisémitisme on disait
très souvent en particulier avec
Jean-Marie Le Pen et bien il vient
toujours du même horizon que l'horizon
de l'extrême droite et là ce que l'on a
vu de très intéressant mais peut-être de
très inquiétant c'était qu'il y avait
oui un antisémitisme de gauche de la
gauche extrême qui n'est pas si nouveau
que cela d'ailleurs qui a toujours
existé dans l'histoire des idées du 19e
siècle à nos jours et d'un antisémit
virulent davantage caché d'ailleurs que
l'antisémitisme de l'extrême droite
parce qu'il se cache sous
l'antisciionisme sous l'hostilité en
effet à Israël mais on a bien vu avec
les dérapages en particulier de certains
députés de la France insoumise que
derrière
l'antiionisme se cachait un vulgaire et
violent antisémme mais est-ce que
l'antisémitisme d'extrême droite a pour
autant disparu notamment des des rangs
du rassemblement national
il s'est minoré il est minoré dans le
rassemblement national le rassemblement
national n'est pas tout à fait à cet
égard le Front national des années 80 je
ne crois ça serait pas sérieux de dire
FN et galeren sur ce sur ce terrain sur
d'autres on pourrait très bien la
comparaison pourrait être raisonnable
mais là non et quantitativement quand
vous regardez aujourd'hui celles et ceux
qui dans la société française continuent
à avoir des comportements des attitudes
antisémite là de manière claire oui il y
a des antisémites à l'extrême droite
mais il y a de nombreux
antisémites en particulier à la gauche
de la gauche et il faut bien le dire
dans la population des Français
musulmans Richard ver qu'est-ce qui vous
a frappé ce jour-là la fraternité qui
est un mot je
trouve qui malheureusement est trop peu
souvent en avant en France ces temps-ci
la fraternité parce que c'est vraiment
c'était vraiment le message c'était le
message de cette foule c'était le
message des gens que à qui l'ont parlait
dans cette foule et ça je trouve que
c'était pour la société française et
pour l'image que donne la France dans un
contexte de crise internationale une
très bonne nouvelle alors je mets tout
de suite un bémol qui est un bémol de
calendrier est-ce qu'aujourd'hui avec le
nombre de morts que l'on connaît à Gaza
qui approche je crois les 20000 morts
est-ce que le has selon le Hamas est-ce
que cette marche pourrait avoir lieu
dans les mêmes conditions je m'interroge
je ne sais pas en tout cas ce ce
moment-là fut un moment de fraternité et
la France a besoin de fraternité et je
crois que c'était une bonne
nouvelle votre avis sur oui moi je
rejoins mes deux voisins sur le moment
j'ai ressenti plutôt un sentiment de
soulagement en voyant qu'effectivement
les Français étaient au rendez-vous de
ce ce moment important et avec une
grande dignité une une ambiance plutôt
apaisée je vous rejoins sur le fait que
le contexte est extrêmement évolutif je
pense que le le débat sur la présence ou
non d'Emmanuel Macron était un faux
débat qui a été comme d'habitude un
petit peu instrumentalisé une toute
petite remarque vous disiez que LF n
était pas sauf François Ruffin justement
qui a été défilé non pas à Paris mais à
Strasbourg ce qui lui a valu des
critiques de son camp voilà il cétait
exception intéressante à à relever
Jean-Daniel Levi l'absence d'Emmanuel
Macron est-ce qu'elle impacte l'opinion
ou pas du touts j pas du tout non non ça
a été un vrai sujet de la part de
responsablebl politique dans le cadre
des enquêtes qu'on a pu être amené à
réaliser l'interrogation même sur le
débat la présence ou pas du président
Lapp qui était extrêmement secondaire
on est peut-être dans un climat qui
était un peu différent avec malgré tout
des personnalités institutionnelles à
savoir la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale le président du Sénat qui ont
pris l'initiative officiellement de
cette de cette marche et avec peu de
responsables politiques qui a proprement
parlé été identifié comme étant dans une
forme de de défilé donc il y a peut-être
que c'est inquiétant pour le président
de la réique mais une forme
d'indifférence au fait qu'il a été
présent ou pas dans le cadre de cette
marche organisée contre l'antisémitisme
cette marche était organisé à l'origine
de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale Yenne Bron Pivet et du
président du Sénat on écoute gerérard
lachet si nous sommes aujourd'hui si
nombreux dans cette marche quelque part
c'est aussi que nous avons le devoir de
protéger la République de lutter contre
l'antisémitisme et de le faire avec la
force de la loi dans un état de droit et
c'est le sens profond de notre marche à
cet instant merci à tous
faudra pas simplement que ça soit une
marche faut qu'une marche conduise à une
démarche et cette démarche doit nous
conduire à plus que jamais les valeurs
de la République soit au cœur de notre
engagement et alors Richard on ne vous
avait rien demandé ici mais vous avez
cité Gérard Larcher parmi les
personnalités politiques de l'année
pourquoi pour la sérénité parce que je
trouve que cette institution le Sénat au
fil de cette année d'abord il y a eu
donc les élections sénatoriales on
connaît le positionnement politique du
Sénat il est clair il est à droite il
est conservateurs mais c'est un élément
de sérénité dans la République la
meilleure preuve c'est que la loi sur
l'immigration a été examinée amendée
votée donc pour les Français même vu de
l'étranger on a l'impression
pardonnez-moi que c'est presque
l'institution aujourd'hui qui fonctionne
le mieux dans le dispositif
institutionnel total français le Sénat
fonctionne et donc il faut rendre
hommage à Gérard Larcher et je confirme
personne ne m'avait rien demandé on est
d'accord on a même été un peu surpris
mais mais vous l'auriez pas fait l'an
dernier je pense que cette année
politique effectivement
Mathie des couleurs sous la président
Gerard ararché mais en particulier en
raison du contexte politique parce que
ce qui est vrai pour le débat sur la loi
d'immigration qui a eu lieu au Sénat pas
l'assemblée c'est aussi été le cas pour
les retraites où le débat n'a pas pu
aller jusqu'au bout à l'Assemblée mais a
eu lieu en entier au Sénat merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participer
à ce à ce bilan de l'année politique
2023 l'actualité politique c'est ce soir
sur nos chaînes parlementaires avec une
émission spéciale qui sera consacré à la
commission mixte paritaire sur ce texte
immigration et elle est présentée par et
Brigitte boucher qui est avec nous en
direct Brigitte bonsoir vous attendez la
fumée blanche comme tout le monde oui
bonsoir Thomas effectivement on vous
prépare une émission spéciale on attend
cette fumée blanche pour l'instant la
commission mixte paritaire n'a toujours
pas trouvé d'accord sur le projet de loi
immigration députés et sénateurs et bien
ont suspendu cette séance jusqu'à 21h il
y a encore des des points
d'achopement bon je je vous ai pas
entendu mais j'espère que nos
téléspectateurs vous ont entendu
Brigitte merci beaucoup et et bonne
bonnem merci à tous encore une fois
d'avoir participé à à ce numéro de de
sens public je voudrais vous informer
aussi que demain dans la matinale Orian
mansini reçoit Bruno rotaillot le
président du groupe LR au Sénat
décidément au cœur de cette actualité
politique bonne
soirée